let's do lunch money that's that's the
most important thing of the day planner
hello welcome how are you nice to see
you ow the more i listen to you do these
ads the more i'm like we really wouldn't
have been friends in high school would
we hey listen if you want a great ad
read i got you who would have ripped off
their pants literally
literally every single jv basketball
player or middle school i've never seen
that before because i hate to break it
to you you were a nerd you were in the
library there's no breakaway pants in
the library y'all had pencils behind
your ear and little pen protectors in
your pocket and in my in my exactly
while you were doing that i was out on
the basketball court dribbling off my
toes don't worry guys these hoodies
these trillionaire energy hoodies are so
exclusive i don't even have one a couple
people are saying they still have pairs
of the breakaway pants oh my god is
every guy like literally that was the
thing if you don't know about it you're
not athletic should i get some let's go
state of crypto what's up
ah you don't want me getting those wind
breakers okay andreessen horowitz which
is a16z the notable venture capital firm
has released its inaugural state of
crypto report that includes
cyclical cyclical information relevant
to the current downturn anthony i'm
listening sorry somebody just text me
something important
if it's not me it's not important
other key right other key takeaways were
related to web3 benefits and ethereum's
continued blockchain dominance so i read
some of it
and i thought it was interesting that
they were talking about the fact that
the crypto market is driven by a cycle
where strong digital asset prices
attract talented into the space
developers innovate during a downturn
and the resulting projects
will drive optimism once the bear market
is over
bitcoin's marketing department is the
price
very important detail bitcoin's price is
the marketing department you have a
decentralized organization
truly decentralized the network is
decentralized the investors are
decentralized there's no ceo there's no
marketing department there's no board of
directors there's no venture capital
none of that stuff and so
how do you get people to learn about it
well the price goes up when the price
goes up the people who already hold it
they start talking about oh [ __ ] the
price going up all the stuff the media
starts to write articles about it the
price of bitcoin is going up the price
of bitcoin is going up and then what
ends up happening is the people who
don't own any of it say what is that
thing the price is going up etc and so
the price ends up being this marketing
department but in every cycle the price
gets overheated and then there is a
correction and when there is that
correction there are some people who
leave there's churn it's no different
than if you and i started a mobile app
and we had zero users what would we do
we'd go run a marketing campaign when we
run that marketing campaign let's say
100 people came in now we have 100 users
but after two weeks 30 of them leave
we're left with 70 users we run another
marketing campaign another 100 users 30
leaves 70 left now we got 140 total
that's what happens with the price is we
continue to get these boom and bust
cycles but every time a boom happens
more people come in they start learning
about it when there's a crash some
people leave there's people leaving
right now bear markets some people are
leaving but there's a lot of people who
weren't here in the last bear market who
are here now and they ain't leaving
and every single time this happens more
and more people end up being here and
what it does is it continues to
establish the uh the the holder base
being decentralized we uh later i think
we're going to talk about
we just crossed over the number of
bitcoin wallet addresses on chain that
have 300 of bitcoin in it we just
crossed over 10 million wallet addresses
now have uh met that threshold which is
all-time high all right next oh we
weren't going to talk about it but if
you want to add a topic
okay um
i didn't have it in my topic list
i'm going to talk about it later oh okay
that's fine that's fine
i thought that was like shade
um
elon
see how paranoid she is
don't shade me
come on okay elon musk said that okay
this is interesting his 44 billion
purchase of twitter will not move ahead
until he has more clarity on how many
accounts are fake he had estimated that
five percent of the mda use so
monetizable daily active users he
thought it was fewer than five percent
were faker spam accounts but now he
estimates it's around 20
of the accounts on twitter are fake or
spam he never estimated it was five
percent they told him it was five
percent twitter estimated in the filing
five or less but okay so he's doing his
due diligence now and he's like oh well
his due diligence includes i tweeted and
i got bombarded with with crypto spam
that's what it means no literally that's
what he was talking about wait what yeah
he was like yeah if you just look at a
hundred users and he's like how many of
them are fake
right and then the best part was then he
tweeted later and he said something like
uh the twitter legal department just
called me and said uh that i violated
the nda by uh saying that the sample
size was only a hundred like you gotta
be kidding me or something whatever he
said and so it just goes back to this
idea there's no way that only five
percent of the users are fake no zero
chain literally zero there's very few
things in life that are zero percent
zero percent chance in my personal
opinion that
there's only five percent of these users
why
because one of the great stats every
single day they claim that they are
nuking 500 000 accounts
that they're getting rid of just 500 000
every single day so if you start to add
that up and you look at their total user
base you're like okay
how accurate are they actually going to
be if they get rid of 500 000 you don't
think maybe a couple of them survive
and guess what when i tweet
just go just go look at the comments
you're like dude it's not that hard
every single time i tweet if this
account goes ahead and post live
giveaway
nuke it i report so many fake anthony's
on twitter like
so my guess is by the way that the only
reason why he's doing this is he's
trying to renegotiate the price uh the
price of all the tech stocks that fall
yeah and he's gonna be successful in
doing it
can he do that after he already agreed
of course he can do anything why because
he says oh uh you guys told me that
there was five users uh five percent or
less were bots i actually think it's
higher prove to me that that's true and
if you don't prove to me that it's true
uh then i'm not buying the company and
they're like oh [ __ ] like we kind of
have to sort of do this this goes back
to a conversation we used to have where
you said like these companies
they basically make revenue based on
their daily active users but there's no
auditing
so yeah yes to a degree but the revenue
is audited so yes i'm talking about the
the whole idea is that companies like
twitter are valued on one of two things
and sometimes both things finances and
user metrics and the finances are we
train cpas
we have very clear definitions of what
is revenue gap non-gaap net income all
this stuff you have to report it on a
quarterly basis
it's audited and there are clear rules
if you violate those rules right there's
clear punishment if you violate those
rules outside of just fraud and all that
stuff there's also clear
rules around uh misleading people
on user metrics
nobody's trained
there's no certification process there's
no equivalent of a cpa in user metrics
but why is it so hard to audit those
the second thing is
the companies don't even use the same
definition your company may say a dau is
somebody who's been active in the last
24 hours my company may say a dau is the
seven day rolling average of users over
a certain period of time yeah so we're
literally comparing not apples to apples
there's no clear standardization of
definitions the third thing is none of
the metrics are audited so how many
times have companies said we have x
number of users and they come out then
go oh you know two quarters ago actually
we miscounted and it's some different
number
then the fourth thing is that there is
no clear uh rules or punishment for if
they mislead people
why do you think that is
because most people are worried about
finance that's where most of the fraud
most of the problems happened in the
past and so when you start to get the
problems in user metrics eventually it
could be 20 years from now eventually
you'll have many of the same rules
because people will the investors will
demand it well because user metrics i
guess is such a new thing relative to
relative to finance which has been
around for you know decades and decades
and decades in you know public market uh
analysis yeah this blows my mind i
always thought they would be audited all
right city group but hold on i was just
gonna say it's this chat is hilarious i
love that
people are like what up diamond what up
waffles is toilet james in there i don't
know oh you don't know about toilet
james guys i know about toilet james
okay he's like he's like the new moist
oh
okay yeah is he looking for a job no no
come on toilet james won't stay on the
toilet he won he won a bitcoin giveaway
one time while he was on the toilet no
he did yeah so we started calling toilet
james oh but that's not his actual
username
citigroup shares it got a boost from
warren buffett who just disclosed a big
stake in the struggling bank
um so finally revealed that buffett's
berkshire hathaway added more than 55
million shares to build a stake worth
2.95 billion as at the end of march i
mean so i mean this is warren's whole
playbook right he's looking for these
like struggling stocks that he thinks
are undervalued and he buys a lot
warren buffett
classic
warren buffett move sit on record and
record and record levels of cash wait
wait wait wait wait everyone including
myself everyone's like dude let's go
let's go let's go
cool as a cucumber just waited bam
stock's down now he's deploying billions
still i think has over 100 billion
dollars sitting there he's trying to
find a really big deal to go do uh but
he has started to much more aggressively
uh deploy capital um and this is this is
just what he does he just waits till
things are so oversold he'll buy him
it'll recover and he's a genius
so like it's more to me actually it's
not about being a quote-unquote a genius
it's more about uh having the discipline
and emotional control when everything's
freaking flying he's just chilling he's
just like just chilling
chill just chill yeah but now that
there's blood in the streets he's
starting to nibble a little bit so he
was kind of
not doing anything when things were hot
true all right next okay this is fun
ubereats is now testing autonomous food
delivery in la and it's collaborating
with two companies to make it happen
motional which is an autonomous vehicle
company and serve robotics which is an
autonomous sidewalk delivery company is
this it's not
okay i think we have a visual maybe of
the
of the uh robot on the sidewalk they
look like humans
no no they're like yellow and boxy and i
think they just go and then open
them so like basically humans are now
the delivery people of the robot like
the robot's more mobility but i still
got to reach in there of course
yeah i mean i don't know how does it do
us to do it in an apartment
was it going to get on the elevator
probably
there it is
see well that little fella does look
kind of nice bella yeah
little fella does look pretty nice so oh
it's got a little it's got a little uh
uh screen so i could it could uh talk to
people uh it's people answering
homemorphize it see you think it's cute
do you want to tell the people i'm not
gonna say it's cute but i am gonna say
that little fellow guys look pretty cool
let me just tell you a quick story
anthony is the ultimate example of
somebody who anthropomorphizes
robots because what does that mean you
you you think they're like human-like
and cute and you feel bad no no no no
i'm the opposite i think that we're
machines okay that's not true but we
were watching a movie
what was the movie called chappy
we couldn't finish the movie because the
robot's arm got cut off and he was like
i can't i can't shut that off listen
why gotta be a bad person you watch
warm-up movies all the time how are you
upset at chat because it's human on
human violence the second one gets a
human on robot violence it's like hey
the robot you programmed the robot so
that it couldn't fight back that's
unfair fighting
he felt really bad for the robot i think
i saw a tear i'm not gonna comment nor
deny they chopped his arm off i was like
damn
he was not happy next okay
oh this is a big hey
sisson listen pay attention
kill joy geologists say that it's not
actually a doorway no you what did they
think it was
they found they think they found an
alien door on mars we have a photo i
believe of this too
tell me this don't look like a door
ladies and gentlemen a mysterious
doorway on mars
it's pretty cool oh boy
i don't know what that is but that shirt
looked like a door to
a
me
says it was probably formed by natural
oh that looks real natural
that looks as natural as somebody making
the door on earth
what do you think is in there though man
i don't know what's in there but i ain't
going i'll send somebody else
i'm gonna send that little robot go
deliver some food let me know if anyone
takes it
i don't know what's in there i don't
know if it's a door but all i do know is
i ain't going through that hole because
that hole looks like you end up in one
of three places just deeper into mars
already kind of weird second is you end
up in like uh the equivalent of an ant
colony but an alien colony underground
where they built all this stuff and you
walk in you're like whoa
the people on earth think don't believe
me on this one or the third one is you
just walk in and you just disappear
like you just
and everyone's like where'd he go and
they're like oh no and they're like well
let's go get them we're like but mars is
literally 16 years away to get there or
whatever it takes uh i guess he's gone
if i was gone on mars would you come get
me no
no
i'd have been so i told you don't go in
the hole
i told you don't go through the door
john your brother john said not a door
don't spread misinformation
john don't know nothing john john be the
first person to be like i wonder what's
behind that door
no
as i was doing research for this i also
recommend you google
mars ufo crash that i mean that looks
real to me listen that's the only
conspiracy theory in the world that i'm
like ah
you might convince me that maybe the
aliens are real
the aliens are we are aliens to other
aliens of course that's my whole idea
that we're just machines you got
software and you got hardware
machine i don't care
go ahead what's the last thing so it's
ask lunch money time and because we're
not having a lot of success now i saw
people asking questions where well they
see that if you guys
saw a hashtag
here's what we're gonna do can you tweet
at us
with the hashtag asklm your questions i
am at paulina underscore marinova can
you can you uh put that in the chat no i
just said john is the man but he ain't
ready for the alien door
and i'll put my own and
door gate they got door gate going on on
mars oh my god why is it going so fast
people love john all right what what is
the question right now so can i ask you
a question sure
if you had to say now what over the last
six months
is the number one lesson you've learned
at post sophia joining us as a new
machine in our machine family
uh wait what have i learned about sophia
no just just like life being a mom
that you can get a lot of stuff done
with very little time and sleep i was
thinking like life is precious or like
love is eternal and then you just hit me
with like a i'm a machine i just can get
a lot of work done the adrenaline is
pumping through my veins
what okay
but also love is eternal babies are
wonderful i hear her crying okay i hope
you guys enjoyed today goodbye palinda
bye all right you can go follow polina
on twitter it's almost 125 thousand
followers that's pretty good 25 8 oh 125
000 yeah let me just teach you how to
count